devastación en las calles de conspiran
la ciudad del este de Ucrania fue
alcanzada por misiles rusos el sábado
tres personas perdieron la vida Mientras
que otras quedaron en medio de los
escombros incluido este hombre que solo
recuperó la matrícula de su coche
algunos tuvieron suerte de estar fuera
de sus casas durante el ataque mientras
que a otros los tomó desprevenidos
puntos
estaba sentada viendo la televisión la
televisión estaba allí
en un momento oí un fuerte ruido no
entendía nada cerré los ojos abrir los
ojos y todo había estallado estaba
cubierta de sangre
pásalo este nicopol en la frontera entre
los territorios controlados por Ucrania
y Rusia los constantes bombardeos de las
fuerzas rusas hacen la vida casi
imposible y hacen que algunos residentes
piensen en evacuar
no hay palabras para esto disparan todos
los días cada vez yo vivo aquí sus
disparos siempre pasan por encima de mi
casa siempre están volando
que disparan los cohetes no puedo dormir
cuando llegamos por la mañana solo
encontramos cenizas no tengo nada que
decirle a esa gente son inhumanos y no
hay nada que decirle a esta gente
inhumana los ataques rusos sean
intensificado en el este y el centro de
Ucrania en los últimos días mientras
Moscú despliega el arma más eficaz de su
Arsenal contra los residentes los
ataques de artillería han dejado un
rastro de ruinas en muchas ciudades
entre ellas aquí en bulevar cerca de
donnietsk Ucrania Confía en que el
aumento de la ayuda militar de occidente
anunciado esta semana como los tanques
estadounidenses abrams y alemanes
leopardos cambie la marea de la guerra
pero por el momento no sirven de
Consuelo a la asediada población del
este de Ucrania